a new book is teaching people how to
thrive and live a more satisfying life
don't we all want that yeah we do it's
called roar goes into the second half of
your life before it's too late it's by
michael clinton now rohr stands for this
reimagine yourself own who you are act
on what's next next and reassess your
relationships to get you there clinton
is also a special media advisor to the
ceo of horse corporation where i am an
editor-at-large for oprah daily roar is
published by atria an imprint of simon
schuster that's a division of viacom cbs
so now that we've gotten all the
disclaimers out of the way let me
introduce you to michael clinton hello
michael very good what's up michael good
morning it's great to be here thank you
so much for having me roar is more than
just a katy perry song i have to say
because you say
it is time to roar will contradict and
challenge everything you thought about
getting older so based on your book you
say forget words like age-appropriate
focus on how about person-appropriate i
like it banished words like retire
three-wire like that we go forget
self-imposed ages and focus on
self-imposed growthism i really like
that i like that and it's not a midlife
crisis it's a midlife awakening because
it's time to awaken and go into the
second half of your life because you say
if you're if you're a healthy 50 year
old
what does that mean you know if you're a
healthy 50 year old today you can
potentially live to be 90. yeah and so
you know the construct we were given
about a post-50 life is sort of blowing
up in the smithereens because you're
having all of these people live into
their 60s and 70s and 80s and you can
have a second career a new love a new
lifestyle so there's a lot of
possibilities in the second half you
always say michael we're your age as a
badge of honor because you know i like
to hear when people say you know 50 is a
new 70 40 is a new 60 you say stop it i
don't like that at all i think you know
60 is the new 60.
i mean 70 is the new 70. i mean look at
these great role models we have you know
jennifer lopez or look at lenny kravitz
i mean he's amazing you know or sting
you know we have a lot of role models in
our public in our public life but i
think we've got a lot of people who are
reimagining what 60 and 70. let's own it
let's just really be proud of it
one of the favorite parts of the book
for me that resonated was owning your
wins and you write about swat strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats in
there you say take out a piece of paper
right and be brutally honest with
yourself yeah which i love
do people need to be more brutally
honest with themselves you know i like
to say
own where you are like take a really
good hard look at where you are right
now and be brutally honest and swat's a
good way to do it you know it's a really
great sort of analysis and and people
tend to not do it
and when you're at that midlife you have
awakened you've lived 25 years so you
can really sit down and think about a
life you've lived so far yeah and get
ready for the next chapter the next
second half you also advise people to
take a hard look at their financial
situation where they are today where
they want to go not a comfortable act
for a lot of people uh let's talk about
life layering though that's another
concept i had not heard before it's in
the book what is it how can i help
people so i think you know one of the
things that people often get tied up in
their seat what they do for a living or
their profession and they forget to
develop other parts of their life so a
life layering you know for me it was
adventure travel i've traveled all over
the world 124 countries and counting i
was just in ethiopia before the pandemic
which was great but i've spent 25 years
cultivating that layer so if you build a
layer of something that's interesting to
you travel photography whatever the case
may be you end up building this really
rich and satisfying life and you can
start that anytime
and you also say this that when you
because you interviewed a lot of people
for this book uh over the age of fifty
how old are you by the way i am 68. okay
a proud sixty-year-old you look great
yeah i think you look 68 is the new 68.
there you go
i'm 66 66. there
but you said when you talk to people
their biggest life regret was what if
they were asked for a redo well you know
we did a survey first of all we
interviewed 40 amazing people i call
them the re-imagineers they are the role
models that we want to follow but we
also did a survey 630 people and one of
the questions was if you could do a
major redo in your life
would you
76 said yes
of the 300 responses
the number one response a third of the
people said i would redo my marriage or
rethink the person that i married yeah
which leads me to this anonymous survey
yeah
but in the book it says if you had to
choose between a wonderful romantic
spouse to whom you'd be married for only
a few years or a boring unromantic
spouse for your entire life which would
you choose for me there is no choice
what was the overwhelming answer it
should be romance right it should be
romance
but there were a lot of undecideds so
that was really that means that they're
thinking yeah they're thinking about it
we often times talk about uh
this world being full of glass half
empty and glass half full people the
glass overflowing right yeah mentioned
glass overflowing and hanging around
those people what do you mean by hanging
out with people who has a glass that's
overflowing yeah you know have those
positive people around you this gets
into the reassess your relationships you
know who are the people who are your
posse you know the people who are really
supporting you
fill you up and surround yourself with
them and you know sometimes you may have
to edit out those people who just you
know aren't doing that i'm all for it
yeah you also say it's never too late to
pivot in life i don't know about that
michael you say it's never too late to
pivot and do something new well i think
you know what's amazing is you know some
great stories in the book a woman at 53
who was a book editor decided to become
a doctor which is you know the journey
that that takes
or you know a 68 year old who's decided
to launch a new business you know the
the biggest cohort of 26 percent of
entrepreneurs in this country are people
55 to 64.
and you know that's a that's a big
number
we always think of the 20 somethings but
it's the 55 to 60 they have the
resources they have the experience they
have the contacts start something new
i'm going to pivot i'm going to
re-launch my life as a 25 year old
there you go how about a marathon runner
i know that
uh michael thank you very much michael
clinton is his name roar is the name of
the book it is on sale wherever you like
to buy your books